[Musique]
et qui dit sport dit forcément michael
et demi d'euros bonsoir bonsoir grégory
en tout cas pour tv 70e
comme chaque lundi vos résultats
sportifs en vous nous livrer les
résultats sportifs du week-end pâques du
football y avait aussi du handball c'est
ça plaisir s'est fait plaisir pour sa
dernière journée en nationale 3 les
plaisirs a déjà assuré de descendre
l'année prochaine on prenait un jeu
offensif face à stella sport se sont
finalement imposés sur le score de 32 à
26 une victoire qui n'aura aucune
conséquence au classement plaisir
termine 10ème sur 12 équipes
il n'aura manqué qu'un point aux joueurs
de victor guerrier pour se maintenir
le bilan de la saison 6 victoires 4 nuls
et 12 défaites rendez vous l'année
prochaine en prénationale direction à
présent montigny le bretonneux toujours
handball mais cette fois ci chez les
féminines dans le championnat de
nationale 2 montigny le bretonneux n'a
pu faire mieux que match nul sur le
terrain de stella sport saint maur ce
samedi soir score final 28 à 28 un
résultat qui n'a aucune conséquence au
classement les i montagne coachée par
denys choulet termine à une décevante
huitième place à 13 points du podium et
11 défaites concédées ont pesé dans la
balance
on parle maintenant baseball nickel en
première division les cougars de monti
le bretonneux jouer ce week-end la 9e
journée du championnat contre les
commerces de metz et les y monta en
remporté la première partie sur le score
de 16 à 0 mais se sont fait surprendre
le second match ils ont perdu 10 à 7 les
cougars reste deuxième de la poule b
avec un bilan de 12 victoires pour 6
défaites et ils sont toujours qualifiés
pour les playoffs de fin de saison leur
prochain match est programmé le 16 juin
prochain à domicile contre le puc de
paris si les sports collectifs sports de
ballon termine par du basket
l'entente le chesnay versailles a connu
un week end magique les seniors se sont
imposés face à à paris en finale de
playoffs de prénationale sur le score de
92 à 60 vous avez bien entendu 92 à 60
le match s'est déroulé sur terrain
neutre dans un final fort à palaiseau
résultat qui leur permet de monter en
nationale 3 la saison prochaine
une année historique merci michael et
l'entente le chesnay-versailles que vous
allez recevoir dans votre émission le
cetud sport c'est dans quelques minutes
assure tv 78